I
you don't you look you look like you're
ready to host the AMAs I am working with
GG you guys go come on how's it being in
the rehearsals are you guys like besties
now yeah man she's so sweet I mean it
almost feels like I've known almost felt
like I've known her food I've known her
for years before I met her and then
we've the last couple of days we've just
been back and forth him we got great
chemistry I'm really excited I gotta ask
you as a man who knows the ins and outs
of Saturday and alive are you at all
surprised that Donald Trump has taken it
so personally the impersonation that
they have done on SNL he's like you know
he's taking it pretty much to heart is
that surprising no she's Donald Trump is
a guide it takes himself very seedy you
know Donald Trump is a Donald Trump is
Donald Trump so he's gonna say something
I think he just wants to tweet stuff for
the retweets he just said stuff to get
retweets on it that's all it is it's
working it's like World Wrestling it's
like WWE watching him him and Kanye's
Twitter's are the funniest to it as the
watch it's like word really son you
didn't see that so yeah man once they
get going yeah I feel like it's all you
know we take jabs at everybody know SNL
take jabs and everybody's ojos whatever
i'll feel like anybody's take themselves
too seriously
you